hello everyone I hope that you are good
today is Monday so I'm going to suggest
you to go to Twitter and read the Sunday
update that I posted yesterday because
you're gonna be able to understand more
my thought process
for this week but so far you know I'm
checking the charts now
um I see that what I said at least the
first part it seems like it might be
playing out because you can see here in
the chat what we got is a week to the
downside okay I'm going to highlight it
this week here to the downside and you
know what I always say about weeks weeks
tend to get filled okay so we are
anticipating
that we visit again at some point this
Zona 26 000 or 25 800 okay now we were
in in a weekend range and we have here
above us
um I would say a resistance is the 50ma
in in the four hour time frame and the
50ma in the daily time frame okay so you
have to do two amazing they're acting as
resistance and I was saying yesterday
that if we came on this first move into
resistance then I'll be looking for
results in this area
probably until Wednesday or Thursday
okay because sometimes in the middle of
the week we can see some time of some
some kind of reversal okay uh and so far
it's playing out um well first I want to
show you here why I chose this uh amas
The 50ma Works in all the time frames
even for scalping in the five minutes or
one minute time frame it is right
um You can see here that's the darker
purple line
um it was resistance in this Zone again
resistance in this Zone support
resistance you can see that you know
price
likes to to play around this 50ma in the
for our time frame but also in the daily
time frame it was a very important
support in the last days of April on the
first days of May okay I'm gonna show
you here you can see this is the the
daily 15. this is support support
resistance resistance okay so you can
see that this 50 Mas in the four hour on
the daily time frame they they play
pretty well so far at least what we've
seen during the last I would say two to
three weeks okay now
um you can see that we are already above
the 50 main the fourth time frame this
Scandal has still 45 minutes until it
closes but yeah it looks like it might
close above the 50ma okay I woke up
quite late today so I'm still not in any
position
um but yet you can see that you know
we're already above the 4 Hour 50ma
let's see how this candle closes but if
you close above it why not we might go
to the next to the next 50ma okay let me
remove them for a second well let me
remove that one for a second because I
want to go now into the one hour time
frame okay and I'm going to show you
what I think is happening okay so we
have a weekend range and then sometimes
it's quite frequent to see on Monday I
fall smooth okay that falls can be
either to the upside or to the downside
I will start getting more to the upside
because I have a quick here that I think
is going to get filled so then I was
expecting that the week was going to be
kind of like the the final Target of the
week okay this might be right might be
wrong but that's what I think then I was
thinking about the idea of an Asia pump
okay so then you have two photos moves
there you have monthly Force move with
an Asian pump okay because I always tell
you that I don't throw sperms during the
Asian session they tend to get retrace
okay so we're gonna play probably today
we're gonna see how the London session
finishes but it's very likely that today
I play with the trading CCT strategy
you have the strategy pinned in my in my
Twitter okay
um Let me let me remove this the weekend
range so let me remove this because I
want to show you okay what I'm talking
about so remember the sessions it would
be the Asian session okay
this will be the sensation over here
uh okay and now we're in the London
session
okay and I always mark it until then you
until the New York session starts
because it takes all the protagonism
so you can see here
okay the what I think
okay that we might see today is
London is holding so if London closes in
this box
thus telling me that there is a you know
high probability that New York reverses
and maybe fills this liquidity pool over
here okay and that's around between 26
800 and 27 100 okay uh so yeah what I
what I'm looking today is to see if
London can hold this box here
um I would even like to see some kind of
sweep of the highs maybe something like
this or why no maybe you can even see
right at the start of the New York
session
this is now
here is now a resistance
so there is a lot of traders that they
are gonna jump into shorts and they're
gonna Place their stop losses right
above this Zone okay so why not we could
even see a sweep of the highs
going as high to be honest
as the daily 50ma why now I've seen this
happening before I know it might look
like a big move this candle but this has
happened before okay
um this should be a big resistance to be
honest okay
um you can see that we've played in in
this song we did something pretty
similar and it's that we came all the
way to the 50ma
get because we lost it for temporarily
and you can see here that I don't think
we're gonna see something like this
today okay uh if it does then I'll be
out of the position I'll be stopped
um because here what you can see is that
I went above the 50ma but any filter
test their support so then you continue
going down all right then you had this
week over here and then price came back
into the Fifth Element resistance down
until the week okay so why not we could
see something like what happened in this
one over here
okay and then fill the wick I mean in
this case it wouldn't be all the way to
down to the week but it could be all the
way down to this liquidity pool
over here okay so I don't even want to
go all the way up today to the Daily
50ma but if we see London holding in
this box then it will be ideal to see a
sweep of the highs it might happen it
might not happening straight away okay
but if we see a sweep of the highs
yeah at the start of the New York
session
okay or
right before he starts then I would love
to take a short okay uh probably will
have invalidation well I'm I'm probably
gonna watch the the chart today in life
because I'm gonna be at home so I'm
gonna see how it plays out first I want
to see if London can hold this zone or
even set a stop hunt and then I like to
take a short ball if London starts to
pump now okay so if London starts to
pump now like this and we see
consolidation here then
you know why not they could promote even
higher so that's what I'm telling you
it's very important the London holes in
this box
for me
to to aim for shorts today
all right hope that's clear
I want to have a look at the dollar
Index because you know that Bitcoin
trades against the XY
um and remember we're pleased uh from
since this happened pretty much okay so
that was almost a month ago I've been
warning you guys the the dollar Index
seems like it might be four minutes okay
um of course if the roller index goes up
Bitcoin is going to go down okay you can
see that the dollar Index has been going
up Thursday and Friday and you check the
chart and see what happened to Bitcoin
now when I see that that was quite a
nasty drop and now to be honest what it
seems to mean but I've told you here
this looks like a sweep of the lows
um and as long as we don't lose this
level over here
that's um
100.48 okay as long as we don't lose
this then the dollar Index might be
forming this WB pattern and that's very
bad for Bitcoin why because if this
plays out
and goes to the upside then Bitcoin is
going to continue going down all right
and the most interesting part of this is
the 50ma again yes you can see a strong
support on all the way up but in this
bull market Florida index the 50ma has
been the main support you can see going
up going up going up now we're at this
point and the volar index is retracing
you know Kuala it went all the way from
115 or 114 to 100 so that's a massive
massive retrace and you can see that now
we've again go above the daily 50 I mean
what can we expect here if we see the
dollar Index you know we've seen the
push up now if we see a retrace and a
retest of this 50ma
then we could see some continuation to
the upside okay and again this would be
really bad for Bitcoin so if you are in
loans or if you uh won't be trying to go
up what you want to see is the dollar
Index losing the 50ma you know that it
fails to test their support and it loses
it and it goes back again to this one
over here otherwise if we test this 50ma
as support it'll have another leg up I
bet we will have another lockdown all
right so that's very important you have
to keep an eye on this okay
so yeah let me wrap this up this is
Bitcoin and not sell today we have our
work to the downside we think it's going
to get failed hopefully this week so
that they don't take ages
um then we also had a weekend range over
here okay sorry for the for these lines
we have how we can range over here we
broke out of the weekend range to the
upside on Monday we usually see false
moves so that could be your first move
of the week and also you have the
Confluence that it was approved during
the Asian session and that's a move that
we don't trust all right so that could
be a double Force move and that's why
I'm not trusting this move we have also
here a lot of resistance the 50 men the
four hour time frame that's the this
purple line here okay now we have only
15 minutes until he closes the candle
ball now it seems like it's closing
below it so let's see how we close this
okay we still have 15 minutes if it
closes below it then we could even see
this Doom
to retrace this liquidity pool over here
even faster okay but I'm expecting it
that if we hold let me go to the one
hour time frame If We Hold
this box over here during the London
session okay so if London holds and
doesn't pump then why anticipating that
in the New York season we see a reversal
okay to the drum set and that would be
to fill this liquidity pool that we can
see over here of course you know we have
here a resistance line so it's possible
that we see a sweep of the highs this
would be an ideal moment to take a short
especially with the Confluence of the
valley 50ma over here at 27 700 let me
market for you guys so that would be
here okay
um if we see a stop control over here
you know I'm taking a short
pretty much okay because I would expect
that we see a strong rejection and
hopefully fill this liquidity pull over
here but again uh let's see how this
candle in the photo time frame closes
because it's possible that we see this
retrace even sooner right so thank you
so much for watching
and I'll see you soon